jochen breyer heute hier bei uns wir
haben achtelfinale dienstag
wembley-stadion deutschland gegen
england und data kickt mit delta kickt
vielleicht nicht unbedingt mit aber
delta sitzt wahrscheinlich auf der
tribüne und jubelt vielleicht mit ihm
vorstellen dass sich delta freuen würde
wenn viele tore fallen und möglichst
viele menschen sich um den hals fallen
und vielleicht das delta auch er england
fan als deutschland fan wollte sich dann
die massen danach auch noch in den bars
treffen
ich hätte mir wirklich nichts lieber
gewünscht als dass man vor diesem
besonderen spiel und das ist ja wirklich
ein sehr besonderes spiel deutschland
gegen england über die sportlichen
themen sprechen kann über die historie
sprechen kann über das wembley tor 66
von dem wir alle wissen dass es kein tor
war sieht man auf der insel gleich ein
bisschen anders aber klar also
spätestens seit wir wissen dass bei dem
spiel dänemark gegen belgien 3 fans mit
der delta variante in kopenhagen im
stall in brand
wie viele tausend leute werden jetzt
getestet das ist doch ein albtraum auch
für jede organisation so einen reise
zirkus um eine europameisterschaft zu
organisieren das ist eine schöne idee
aber in kurzer zeit einen
verantwortungslos es ist wirklich eine
charmante idee gewesen und es gibt auch
wirklich schöne momente also hin mit
diane goldbeck im studio gesprochen
dänischer nationalspieler der sagt das
ist das allergrößte für uns in dänemark
dass wir ein turnier zu hause haben wir
sind so ein kleines land wir hätten nie
ein turnier alleine aber in diesen
zeiten ich glaube es wäre besser gewesen
sich in anderen modus auszudenken in
dieser pandemie um zu sagen diese idee
in elf oder zwölf ländern die
verschieben wir auf die zeit nach der
pandemie und die uefa hat offensichtlich
mehr angst vor regen bogen fahren als
frau corinna so ist das leider also man
hat tatsächlich den eindruck dass die
gesundheit da nicht im vordergrund steht
sondern die interessen der geldgeber
tatsächlich also das schlägt sich sowohl
bei den zuschauerzahlen nieder die uefa
will natürlich ein produkt haben die wir
ein produkt vermarkten und will da
stimmung im stadion aber sie will jetzt
zum beispiel auch ihre sponsoren
durchdrücken 2500 jobs sollen zum finale
einreisen sollen sich nicht an die
quarantäne regeln halten müssen und
da entsteht tatsächlich der eindruck
dass der uefa hat ihre geldgeber
wichtiger sind ihre sponsoren wichtiger
sind als die gesundheit darf das auf gar
keinen fall passieren fragezeichen das
was sagen die briten dazu wollen wir
wenigstens wissen und zwar sofort von
diana zimmermann der leiterin des zdf
studios in london einen guten abend
dienstag werden 45.000 menschen im
wembley stadion sein beim halbfinale
sogar 60.000 diana bestimmt eigentlich
wie vor so ein stadion sein da fangen
wir mal da an
ja das hat natürlich die regierung
gestimmt die englische
gesundheitsbehörde findet das keine gute
idee
dazu muss man wissen normalerweise hätte
hier ja am montag der freedom day
stattfinden sollen das war das von boris
johnson großartig angekündigte datum zu
dem alle restriktionen in großbritannien
hätten fallen sollen vor allen dingen
eben in england das konnte nicht
geschehen wegen der data variante weil
wir eben jetzt in großbritannien wieder
die höchste instanz von ganz europa
haben
deswegen wurde dieser freedom day
verschoben und deswegen sind alle spiele
die jetzt nach dem ersten freedom day
hätten stattfinden sollen nicht im
freedom day sondern finden danach stadt
und deswegen hätten sich was schlaues
einfangen lassen er hat jetzt erklärt
dass sein alles testspiele test events
für den freedom day der jetzt für den 19
juli angesetzt ist also angeblich werden
hier die ganze zeit sehr wichtige daten
gesammelt tatsächlich aber wäre es
natürlich ein fürchterlicher image
verlust gewesen wenn boris johnson diese
spiele hätte zurückziehen müssen
und er hat sich natürlich von der uefa
unter druck setzen lassen zumal selbst
sehr gerne nach dem lustprinzip agiert
und wissenschaftlichen experten nur
insoweit folgt als das mit seiner
politik zusammen passt ja und konnte
oder wollte er sich nicht durchsetzen
gegenüber der uefa
na ja es geht ja nicht um leben oder tod
sondern nur ein fußballspiel auch wenn
viele leute das ähnlich wichtig sehen er
hätte natürlich sagen können wir machen
das nicht und dann hätte die uefa ihre
androhung wahr machen können oder auch
nicht diese spieler aus london
abzuziehen
aber natürlich ist das eine imagefrage
und eine regierung die so auch
symbolpolitik setzt und ein premier der
so viel von dem freedom day gesprochen
hatte und dann diese wichtigen spiele
absagen muss das hätte natürlich nicht
gut ausgesehen
das wollte er nicht machen das wollte er
nicht machen claudia kade ist bei uns
journalisten kolleginnen geschätzte
journalistenkollegen ressortleiterin
politik bei der weltpokal
volle ränge in ländern die eine viel
höhere instanz haben als wir hier in
deutschland werden wir schon mal werden
die deutschen schon mal europameister
der angst ja also ich würde auch nicht
total übertreibe und sagen das ist jetzt
durch diese irgendwie ein game changer
passiert das glaube ich nicht obwohl ich
natürlich keine biologin bin aber in dem
fortschritt und sowas haben wir ja schon
was mich nur wundert ist dass gerade bei
diesem konzept der em wo es ja durch die
verschiedenen staaten geht und eben auch
mit großbritannien ein virus varianten
gebiet dabei ist dass wir tatsächlich
ist bis dahin bis jetzt noch nicht
geschafft haben einheitliche regeln in
den eu-staaten mitreisenden aus diesen
ländern zu finden festzulegen weil sie
die regeln in deutschland relativ
strengen mit quarantäne in beiden
richtungen aber man kann natürlich über
andere länder zurück kommen in denen das
nicht so streng gehandhabt wird und da
haben wir die freizügigkeit in der eu
also da kann man
das leicht umgehen und ich verstehe
eigentlich nicht wie wir nach 16 monaten
in der pandemie das immer noch nicht
politisch auf eu-ebene hinbekommen haben
und gerade jetzt finde ich wäre es
wirklich an der zeit jetzt sitzen ja
auch die user zum regional und gab 1
nach 16 monaten fiel auf und ein dass
man sich vielleicht abstimmung sollte
bis hin zu spät würde ich mal sagen ja
wir sind mit karl lauterbach verbunden
und zwar in hamburg diesmal nicht hier
in berlin im studio sondern aus hamburg
zugeschaltet herr lauterbach sie haben
sich gewünscht dass das endspiel auf gar
keinen fall in london stattfinden sollte
gewünscht kann man nicht sagen also wenn
sie es denn entscheiden müssten
warum sind selbst geimpften menschen
geimpfte fans in ihren augen nicht
sicher die geimpften fans sind da nicht
sicher wenn sie nur einmal geimpft
wurden
tatsächlich ist bei dieser data variante
der unterschied zwischen der ersten und
der zweiten impfung sehr groß also die
erste impfung schützt relativ wenig nach
der zweiten impfung ist man aber sehr
gut geschützt und also in england sind
sehr viele fans ein einziges mal bisher
gegeben worden und es gibt natürlich
auch noch ungeimpfte somit ist das also
eine gelegenheit dass die drei und dass
ich also in england noch weiter also
verbreitet es sind natürlich auch fans
angereist und diese angereisten fans
können sich infizieren dass es insgesamt
wenn man so wird ein brandbeschleuniger
für die data variante die uns deshalb
diese großen probleme macht und die sich
anschickt die entscheidende die
dominierende variante in ganz europa zu
sein das ist insgesamt also weder
epidemiologisch noch so symbolisch ist
es eine kluge entscheidung
ich hätte es richtig gefunden wenn man
gesagt hätte dass an dem ort wo die
gefährlichste variante mit der höchsten
instanz in ganz europa derzeit also
vorher ich dass man dort nicht ein
fußballspiel vor 60.000 zuschauern
durchführt das wäre
wir fragen gleich nach der alternative
nochmal zu die anderen zimmermann 80
prozent der briten haben wir schon
gehört sind erst gehen 60 prozent der
briten haben diese zweite impfung
wie ist denn damit natürlich
spitzenreiter in europa und in der welt
wie ist es überhaupt möglich dass dieses
delta so eine impf mauer am himmel
versagen überspringen kann
naja 60 prozent doppelt wir sind ja
immer noch 40 prozent nicht doppelt
geimpft und wie herr lauterbach gerade
sagte wirkt eben der impfstoff nach
einfach impfungen gegen delta nicht so
besonders gut
es ist so dass 40 prozent der
krankenhauspatienten momentan
tatsächlich am einfach oder zweifach
geimpft sind etwa sieben prozent der
delta patienten oder der infizierten
auch sind sogar doppelt geimpft bei
denen hat der impfschutz einfach nicht
richtig funktioniert und 40 prozent der
briten ist natürlich eine unglaubliche
menge das virus verbreitet sich massiv
in den jüngeren generationen deswegen
hatten wir zum beispiel letzte woche
hier in england 250.000 schulkinder die
sich isolieren mussten und es sind eben
die jüngeren leute die einfach oder noch
gar nicht geimpft sind bei denen das
momentan sich so ausbreiten und wir
gehen wieder zurück an diesen tisch und
freuen uns über die anwesenheit von
gerhard physiker aerosol forscher sie
beraten das robert-koch-institut herr
scheuch und der dfb zitiert sie auf
seiner homepage mit dem schönen satz
fußball ist völlig unbedenklich
haben sie denn nur das kicken gemeint
oder haben sie auch das drumherum
gemeint und die zuschauer und die sich
umarmenden fans die umarmen den fans
sicherlich nicht nur ausschließlich aber
schon die zuschauer
ich glaube und das sind wir uns in der
eu soll forschung ja relativ einig dass
draußen so gut wie keine ansteckung
stattfinden und das gilt auch in einem
stadion
die ansteckung finden dann statt in der
anreise bei der anreise oder in
geschlossenen räumen in den logen ja da
wo eben die leute länger zusammen sind
wir wissen gerade aus finnland sind fans
zurückgereist aus petersburg die bahn
finanziert und das waren genau die die
mit den bussen gefahren sind
sie haben sich nicht im stadion
angesteckt sondern im bus deswegen im
stadion selbst wird gar nicht so viel
passieren aber es ist eben wenn 60.000
leute zusammenkommen dann
muss an und abreise funktionieren sind
taxifahrten da sind busfahrten das in
toilettenanlagen das in logen und das
sind die und das sind die die die spots
wo es dann wo es dann geraten kann nicht
so sehr im freien da passiert
die europäischen regierungschefs die
jetzt gerade sich zu dem gipfel
getroffen haben in brüssel
da bemerkte frau merkel auch dass eben
portugal gerade so zu leiden hat viele
englische touristen nach portugal gingen
da würden sie auch wieder sagen das ist
nicht deren schlichte anwesenheit in
diesem land sondern es ist der weg dahin
das reisen das ist sicherlich nicht das
anwesen sei er am strand das haben wir
im letzten jahr auch gelebt erlebten
volle strände und da ist nichts passiert
das passiert in den ja in den
verkehrsmitteln es passiert in den engen
engen räumen wo die erosion beute steht
das ist eben dieses teuflische an diesem
virus dass es über eurozone übertragen
wird und sie kommen in einen raum in dem
ist gar keiner mehr drin da war aber
vielleicht vorher ein infizierter drin
und dann stecken sie sich an und sie
wissen nicht wo sie sich angesteckt
haben
ja das ist eben das verrückte bei diesem
virus und das passiert aber nur
einräumen das passiert nicht im freien
und deshalb finden sie wichtiger dass
wir uns darauf konzentrieren
lauterbach sie uns interessiert
natürlich in ihre meinung dazu würden
sie damit gehen herr söder hat er jetzt
aus münchen schon mal münchen angeboten
fürs endspiel aber auch da ist ja nun
erschreckenderweise oder
interessanterweise diese data variante
auf dem vormarsch 25 prozent in münchen
deutschlandweit bei 15,1 wenn ich es mir
richtig gemerkt habe was wäre denn in
münchen und in bayern aus ihrer warte
sicherer und würden sie auch sagen
eigentlich ist dieses stadionrund nicht
das problem da ist viel wurde noch na ja
wenn da ein stadion so voll ist nach
60.000 zuschauer dann stehen die
zuschauer sehr nahe beieinander und es
kommt dann tatsächlich sehr auf das also
auf das wetter im wahrsten sinne des
wortes an wenn die luft nicht steht
sondern da ist ein bisschen wind das
wird weggeblasen usw
vorteile sind eine ganz andere situation
als wenn es schlicht und ergreifend
windstill ist die fußball fans also
schreien laut also man muss sich das wie
folgt vorstellen in einem milliliter
luft also sind bei der data variante zum
teil 100 millionen während das also
bedeutet ein milliliter luft hat zu
viele wären wie deutschland einwohner
hat und wenn jetzt also quasi laut
geschehen wird gesprochen wird gesungen
wird dann kommen dort enorme virus
zahlen zusammen und also delta ist halt
sehr ansteckend ich brauche gar nicht so
viel viruslast somit kann ich mir sogar
vorstellen dass man auch in einer also
stadion und situationen wo man also dann
eng beieinander steht und singt oder
laut schallt das man sieht man sich dort
an stellt er in diesen wünschen wir in
münchen wäre die situation anders also
erstens macht das einen unterschied ob
ich sage mal über 90 prozent der virus
habe oder 25 und zum 2
in münchen würden wir natürlich nicht
das stadion mit 60.000 leuten für den
sondern drinnen in münchen jetzt also
hiermit wegen 15.000 also leute ins
stadion ließ das ein sehr lustiges
stadium man hätte also einen also delta
anteil von vielleicht 25 prozent zu dem
zeitpunkt also eine ganz andere gefahren
situation da ist doch sofort die frage
an den sportreporter jochen breyer
können sie sich so ein furioses
fußballfest vorstellen über 90 minuten
und der sitzt man mit abstand und mit
maske kann ich mir vorstellen wenn es
ein 0 0 ist ein langweiliges spiel ohne
torraumszenen und ohne spannung aber
ansonsten natürlich nicht weil das ist
ja genau das was den fußball ausmacht
also klar gehen wir auch ins stadion um
schöne spielzüge zu sehen schöne tore zu
sehen aber es ist ja das
gemeinschaftserlebnis es ist ja die
emotionen und wenn wir an den letzten
montag denken als die denn zu hause
gespielt haben in kopenhagen im letzten
spiel es doch noch geschafft haben ein
kleines fußballmärchen zu schaffen
die sind 4 2 gegen gegen russland da ist
ein mehr als fußball fan das herz
aufgegangen
bei diesem tor von christen sind wo dann
sich alle in den armen lagen und sich
abgeknutscht haben und so weiter und die
masken flogen nur so durch die luft das
ist fußball und also ganz ohne emotionen
ist fußball natürlich nicht fußball
würden sie denn sagen herr scheuch dass
man auf die masten jetzt draußen
verzichten kann der bayerische
gesundheitsminister diagnostiziert bei
den deutschen fans schon mal eine maske
allergie würde ich sagen
man kann beim feiern draußen da ein
bisschen vorsichtiger sein
also beim feiern draußen auf jeden fall
da kann man die maske sicherlich ablegen
ich möchte das aber nochmal in die
relation bringen also wenn wir wenn wir
uns jetzt mal die inzidenz 'nen angucken
england ist sicherlich jetzt eine
ausnahme ich ich wäre auch nicht nach
london gegangen mit dem endspiel jetzt
also aber wir haben eine inzidenz im
augenblick in deutschland von 677
infizierte auf 100000 das heißt sie
haben jetzt ein stadion voll und sie
würden überhaupt keine kontrolle machen
dann hätten sie in dem ganzen stadion
mit 10.000 leuten 0,7 infizierte im
schnitt statistisch das ist ja nicht so
dass jetzt neben ihnen neben jedem ein
infizierter sitzt 0,7 infizierte im
schnitt ja das müssen wir immer in die
relation setzen das heißt selbst im
wembley-stadion jetzt in london
da werden ja nicht 200 infiziertes sein
selbst bei der incident von 100 sind das
vielleicht 2 1 zwei hände voll das ist
blöd wenn man dann genau neben so einem
sitzt ja aber dieser eine wird nicht das
ganze stadion rund anstecken das ist der
unterschied in innenräumen wenn wir hier
einen drin hätten ja dann steckt er uns
alle das ist nicht dabei der unterschied
ist ja tatsächlich deshalb sind wir alle
getestet die wir hier sitzen nicht
einmal kurz da herrschen gehen darf
dabei ist natürlich die signalwirkung
die signalwirkung die von vollen stadien
ausgeht ist für die bevölkerung es ist
in ordnung dichtgedrängt fußballspiele
zu schauen und das ist das wo vorher die
experten hier ganz besonders warmen es
gibt schon schottische zahlen dazu wie
der anteil sich von männern bei den
infizierten in den letzten zehn tagen
erhöht hat seitdem begonnen
dass der anteil von frauen und männern
gleich war leicht war in der infektion
und seit der em ist es so dass männer
zwei drittel der infektionen ausmachen
und frauen nur ein drittel und die
experten führen das eben auf das
gemeinsame fußballschauen zurück diana
sie haben vorhin so gut
beschrieben wie mit diesem freedom day
umgegangen wird auf der anderen seite
sind die stadien voll und jetzt wird
verschoben
wie finden die briten das denn das ist
volle stadien in großbritannien gibt wie
kommen die mit diesem eigentümlichen
symbol zu stande
zur entschuldigung also die die
zigtausenden die karten für wembley
haben am dienstag finden das ist die
anderen sind eher skeptisch
insgesamt ist es natürlich so dass in
großbritannien viele auch die regeln
schon gar nicht mehr so richtig beachten
und nicht mehr so richtig
vorsichtig sind weil sie auch erschöpft
sind auch von den großen ankündigungen
die dann immer nicht eingehalten werden
aber die kommentare hier sind schon sehr
in die richtung warum dürfen wir
nirgendwohin fahren in urlaub angela
merkel appelliert an alle europäischen
ländern zwei wochen quarantäne für die
briten einzuführen weil hier die delta
variante grassiert und gleichzeitig
machen wir gigantische fußballspiele
also das sorgt schon für einigen unmut
von den armen leuten die aus
virusvarianten regionen hierher kommen
und in quarantäne hotels sitzen gar
nicht zu reden
die sind wie man auf twitter nachlesen
kann wirklich außer sich vor wut so was
man ja wirklich überhaupt nicht versteht
ist dass die zuschauerzahl jetzt steigt
in london also wir hatten in der
vorrunde eine moderate inzidenz der
waren 22.500 zuschauer erlaubt
ich steige die insolvenz aber die
zuschauerzahl steigt auch genau wir
verdoppeln jetzt und steigen dann beim
finale bei 16 60 absurd wenn wir den
sommer nochmal anführen und auch wissen
das ist offensichtlich da haben sie
gesagt das virus vom sommerwetter
gebremst wird dass sie diesen effekt
auch unterschätzt hätten
wir haben ja jetzt wirklich in unserem
land wie herr professor scheuch sagt
eine sehr niedrige inzidenz lag das denn
dass wir so heil und geheilt so zu sagen
jetzt erst mal in diesem sommer
schreiten lag das an dem virus oder lag
es an uns ist es also wirklich so dass
wir im sommer insgesamt freier atmen
können es ist so also tatsächlich haben
neuere studien
die saisonalität des virus die stärker
betonen könne herausarbeiten können eine
sehr wichtige arbeit von der oxford
universität modellierung konnte
nachweisen dass die saisonalität
ungefähr 40 prozent des wertes aus macht
das sonst eine nährwert von also ein reh
produktionswert also meinetwegen 1 hätte
dass ich für jeden der neue sich
infiziert wieder einen finden der den
derjenige dann infiziert dass das
ungleichgewicht hat dann geht das dann
runter auf 06 es heisst sich sehr stark
ab dass spielt eine rolle was auch eine
rolle gespielt hat
was mir nach wie vor unterschätzen ist
wir testen wie die weltmeister
mittlerweile also ganz europa gehört
nirgendwo so viel getestet wie bei uns
und diese testungen die helfen die
superstars zu identifizieren und das
exponentielle wachstum beim asco fuß
setzt ja immer voraus dass es super
spreading gibt die nur die superstar
machen
das exponentielle wachstum und die
superstar können sehr gute identifiziert
werden können mit dem schnelltest
übersehen
vier von zehn positiven ganz allgemein
aber kaum einen super spacer und durch
dieses massenhafte testen was wir
gemacht haben haben wir sehr viele super
später identifiziert und haben
wesentlich mit dazu beigetragen dass die
fallzahlen runtergegangen sind somit
griffen da ein paar positive maßnahmen
ineinander wir haben glück gehabt und
das richtige getan und dann sind wir
jetzt ja trotzdem noch mal bei der
europameisterschaft und sie würden sagen
herr lauterbach in welcher größenordnung
und in welcher ansammlungen wären den
treffen von menschen in stadien okay
also ich bin da ungefähr der gleichen
meinung wie schaue ich hatte zwar diese
also vollen stadien für etwas
gefährlicher als nichts zu halten
scheint aber werden die menschen
meinetwegen in den stadien weit
voneinander entfernt stehen abstand von
anderthalb metern also da würde ich auch
ohne maske mir gut vorstellen können
dass man im stadion steht und dann kann
man ja ausrechnen was das ausmacht also
wenn du so ein stadion ist von
meinetwegen 70.000 menschen das fast
70.000 menschen dann also
kann ich da leichter 14.000 reinpacken
und habe trotzdem noch den abstand der
sicher macht dort sogar ohne maske zu
stehen ich würde die maske beim
reingehen verwenden also weil wir
eingehen also da steht man sehr eng
beieinander auch bei der anfahrt abreise
also ein ausgang
aber wenn man erst mal sauber im stadion
steht dann könnte ich mir beim stadion
von 70.000 leuten an der verpackung von
14.000 vorstellen ohne dass das also
auch ohne maske ein risiko darstellt da
kriege ich dann den einen oder anderen
infizierten aber kein superstar ding so
dass haben er hat die uefa nun schon mal
anders entschieden so weit waren wir
bereits claudia kade wenn man sich
erinnert noch einmal an diese
unendlichen diskussionen über
großveranstaltungen die wir ja auch hier
in deutschland geführt haben egal ob in
innenräumen oder aber auch draußen kann
sich der fußball da tatsächlich
irgendwie wirklich immer ne extrawurst
braten haben sie ein verständnis dafür
dass es immer wieder ausnahmen auch gibt
für diese begegnungen rund um den
fußball
ja also ich habe ein gewisses
verständnis dafür sie hatten es ja sehr
schön erklärt dass eben auch druck
tatsächlich kommt von der uefa und das
da zwänge aus dringe druck ausgeübt wird
unseren zwänge wirken aber natürlich hat
das eben auch eine gesellschaftliche
funktion so eine so ein turnier und eben
auch die das zu ermöglichen dass die
menschen da zusammenkommen
von daher es gab ja diese ganze das
conti-management zumindest in
deutschland hat ja immer eigentlich sehr
vergnügen feiern sollten wir alle dass
das ohne dass das sollte eigentlich also
dafür waren die tests zum beispiel auch
nicht gedacht dafür shoppen es aber sie
noch wie angela merkel das gesagt hat
shoppen und testen und so also test
bitte nur für zum arbeiten oder für die
für die für die ganz harten dinge des
lebens
ich finde man muss mit zunehmendem
fortschritt auch stärker unterscheiden
zwischen infektion und schwere
erkrankung also je besser wir alle die
mehr von uns geimpft sind auch eben
damit erstmal weniger schwer werden wir
erkranken deswegen deswegen es kann dann
trotzdem infektionen geben aber der
schweren krankheitsverlauf der wird dann
in der masse
so nachdem erkenntnissen wir bisher
haben so nicht mehr massiv auftreten und
ich glaube diese differenzierung wir
sind noch nicht so weit werden wir sind
noch sind ja noch beim impfen jetzt geht
es langsam komme mir wissen meinen vater
aber wir sind wahrscheinlich noch nicht
an dem punkt wir wissen auch nicht wann
ist die herdenimmunität eigentlich
wirklich gegeben gerade bei delta dann
müssen wir das nicht aber ich glaube im
zunehmendem verlauf müssen wir da
stärker unterscheiden zwischen
infektionen also incident wunder neben
und beschwörungen erkrankt werden gehen
wir noch mal zu diana zimmermann nach
london
in 90 minuten spaß haben in england
das wird den deutschen diana deutschen
zuschauern deutschen fans nun schon mal
gar nicht möglich sein beim achtelfinale
und auch er nicht beim halbfinale und
finale weil es im grunde unlösbare
bedingungen gibt also unlösbar kann man
nicht sagen aber doch ziemlich harte
bedingungen bevor man von deutschland
aus nach großbritannien einreist muss
man sich erst mal einen test besorgen um
ins flugzeug zu steigen
das geht ganz vorher muss man sich ein
doppeltes testkit bestellen
das kostet etwa 200 euro und diese
dieser test muss einmal zweiter und am
achten tag benutzen am fünften her kann
man sich noch ein test bestellen noch
mal für etwa 100 euro damit man am
sechsten tag dann raus darf und bei der
rückreise das hatten wir schon muss man
eben zwei wochen in deutschland in
quarantäne
ohne dass man sich da irgendwie raus
testen kann das ist eine frage an den
sportreporter wie viele fans werden sich
bei diesen kuscheligen bedingungen auf
den weg machen sie wenn sie jetzt mal so
unter uns ich glaube ehrlich gesagt
nicht so viele also 1000 er hätte ja
jetzt schon sehr spontan sein müssen
fünf tage das heißt man hätte eigentlich
gestern schon einreisen müssen also
gestern sich direkt auf den weg machen
und einreisen damit man sich dann geht
einheitstag freitags lassen kann und der
dfb hat eigentlich 10.000 tickets zur
verfügung nimmt aber nur 2000 und
verteilt die an deutsche in
großbritannien in england es wird
sicherlich einige geben das spiel ist ja
auch ein magnet deutschland gegen
england aber ich glaube nicht dass es
viele
und eigentlich tickets gibt's schon mal
gar nicht für leute die eben nicht in
großbritannien zu hause sind oder auf
den britischen inseln richtig zu ist
also tickets kriegt man sowieso mit
nicht man kann dann maximal sich darüber
freuen es in
in einem pub zu gucken wir sind herr
lauterbach wieder in deutschland und
fragen uns wo können denn jetzt aber
deutsche fans in deutschland wenn sie
schon nicht nach england reisen feiern
wo darf man das noch wo sollte man das
machen und ist es unbedenklich in ihren
augen
es ist dann unbedenklich wenn die
abstände gewährleistet sind und also man
also dass tatsächlich zivilisiert macht
also was mir sehr gut vorstellen kann
beispielsweise in biergärten wo große
leinwände sind oder vor restaurants also
dass die restaurants dann draußen
entsprechende leinwände aufbauen was
gefährlich wäre es eben drinnen das ist
tatsächlich riskant also das problem
also mit der data variante ist das also
soviel virus ausgeschieden wird und dass
die ansteckung so starke somit also bei
der quote die wir derzeit haben also wir
haben nur einen drittel voll geimpfte
und also etwas mehr als 50% tage im
spital geimpften helfen hier nicht
wirklich somit sind wir unter auf einen
drittel des zwei drittel der bevölkerung
sind nach wie vor also variante offen
da können wir es uns nicht leisten die
spiele drinnen zuschauen somit draußen
ja ich also kann mir gut vorstellen wenn
man da mit mann wegen einem meter
abstand oder einem halben meter abstand
von mir aus auch zueinander sitzt als
ich ein kleiner der abstand ist desto
wahrscheinlicher ist dass man die maske
tragen sollte aber einen meter oder so
geht auch gut ohne maske dann also sind
diese spiele draußen gut organisierter
und da hätte ich überhaupt kein problem
auch wenn der 1 200 leute zusammensitzen
okay fangen wir auch gerhard scheuch
noch mal platz lassen testen lüften
funktionieren diese konzepte denn in
ihren augen für innenräume jetzt in der
zeit in der wir leben
das scheint so zu sein dass die auch
funktionieren ja man kann natürlich
jetzt im sommer mehr lüften
dadurch schafft man ja quasi bedingungen
wie draußen in den innenräumen
aber ich stimme herrn lauda war
vollkommen zu am besten wenn man sich
jetzt schon zum public viewing gibt dann
eben draußen das ist dann sehr
ungefährlich da wird nicht viel
passieren
und wenn man dann ein bisschen abstand
einhält und nicht zu kuschelig das ganze
spiel guckt dann glaube ich dann kommt
man ganz gut dadurch also zumal wir ja
in deutschland jetzt sehr sehr niedrigen
zinsen haben fünf 600.000 das ist dann
schon sehr niedriger irgendwann muss man
ja mal wieder da und man wird claudia
kade doch den jungen leuten jetzt
irgendwie den menschen also jeder müssen
ja nicht nur junge leute seien nicht
verbieten oder untersagen können auch in
den parks zu feiern also gestern waren
das noch illegale partys und die polizei
ist eingeschritten
wie lange wird sie das noch tun können
erst recht wenn die em jetzt wider
erwarten so wahnsinnig gut für den
deutschen bliebe ja ich denke auch dass
wird wird sich in grenzen halten in
zukunft ich fand's ehrlich gesagt auch
in der vergangenheit schon in teilen
absurd was da passiert ist also wir
erinnern uns vielleicht noch an bilder
aus hamburg wurde also die polizei einen
jugendlichen durch einen park verfolgt
hat mit dem mit einem streifenwagen also
dieses draußen feiern hat glaube ich
bisher noch nicht die großen super
special events hervorgebracht und ja es
geht eben auch tatsächlich darum dass
man auch den jungen leuten die finde ich
in der pandemie ziemlich
heruntergefallen sind also wenn wir von
den schulkindern oder kita kindern
eigentlich angeht bis zu studierenden da
muss auch da muss man ein signal kommen
es wurde eben auch schon von einem
gesellschaftlichen symbol oder so
gesprochen
das geht auch in die andere richtung
also dass man auch mal tatsächlich sich
genau überlegt wie gefährlich sind die
dinge und müssen wir wirklich von dieser
pauschalen herangehensweise an das panda
als pandemie management mal abrücken und
wirklich kleinteiliger werden und wie
kommt